[Musique]
entre la loire et le berry la sologne
impose son rythme lent parfois figés
dans un paysage de carte postale de
forêt majestueuse et des temps
immémoriaux
pourtant ce qui fait l'esprit de cette
nature sauvage ce sont aussi ses
habitants nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de solognot qui conçoivent ce
petit coin de région centre autrement
celui d'une nature toujours aussi
présente mais à protéger d'un patrimoine
vivant à conserver trois histoires
ancrées sur ce territoire trois
personnages qui perpétuent un savoir
vivre un savoir-faire 100% terroir bien
ok au pied
achille de spar est éleveur de moutons
solognot depuis cinq ans aujourd'hui il
déplace un de ces troupeaux vers de
nouvelles prairies
je me voyais pas une mais autre chose
que du mouton selon l'onu en ce legs
et ça permettait déjà de conserver cette
race là qui étaient quand moi je me suis
installé encore en voie de disparition
et l'autre particularité c'est sa
rusticité son adaptation aux territoires
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on qu'à l'heure
actuelle on est arrivé à une quasiment
une trentaine d'éleveurs en sologne une
centaine d'éleveurs sur le territoire
français
pour le jeune éleveur réintroduire le
mouton solognot sur ses terres d'origine
c'est aussi une ode à la lenteur
certes elles sont moins productives mais
elles ont besoin de moins d'attention
elles sont plus rustique et son et
produisent à un produit qui est de
meilleure qualité sur du long terme mais
une viande qui a une croissance lente et
une gamme de meilleure qualité
donc c'est aussi pour ça que je me suis
orientée là dessus parce que mon idée
générale c'est aussi de produire de la
qualité on est en sologne c'est
il ya une image autour de ça
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là à la ferté
imbault isabelle gasselin maire de ce
village de moins de 1000 habitants
commence sa journée
et benoît
benoît ouvert son garage depuis un mois
un succès pour ce mécanicien qui
cherchait une reconversion
et la venue de trois ans avec madame
gâteries qu'on est sur le projet ouais
donc cola et là il ya une occasion en
fait de l'acquisition du hangar et qui
s'est fait et du coup ça
donc j'ai acheté à titre personnel et
donc je loue à benoît pas peut-être
qu'un jour il rachètera sais pas
l'objectif c'est bien mais
je loue gratuitement en plus que
quelques mois par la chaîne l'objectif
c'est voilà qui s'installe qu'ils
puissent s'insérer correctement dans
bonnes conditions belloy titre personnel
je pense sur mes deniers mois j'ai fait
un crédit pour la haie et moi en
contrepartie j'ai fait les travailleurs
élus en 2014 madame le maire s'est lancé
dans un projet de redynamisation du
centre bourg au village lève j'ai tout
fait pour rester y vivre d'ailleurs en
fait et voilà et je me dis ah oui là un
village sans commerce à un village qui
meurt donc y'a plus rien après
tenter d'effacer son prêt son père
partir je suis rendu compte en fait que
la commune pouvait pas tout faire et au
final ça permet d'activer de créer des
activités supplémentaires
la commune en fait avait des biens donc
avait le la poste là bas elle a toujours
l'épicerie elle avait la boucherie donc
en fait on en a encore et on en vend
aussi
est le fruit de ses ventes a permis de
financer la médiathèque
[Musique]
au pied du château de villesavin h il a
réhabilité le moulin pour en faire sa
ferme j'ai voulu perpétuer
partie agricole l'élevage qu'on a autour
du château de villesavin pour dans un
premier temps rester sur le domaine avec
mes parents et ça me permettait de
dégager un revenu moi personnellement et
ça permet aussi de valoriser les
terrains qu'on a autour
s'engager sur son territoire pour
défendre une autre vision de la sologne
un choix plutôt naturelle pour achille
mais pas uniquement le côté définit
aussi
d'essayer perpétuer aussi une une
agriculture en sologne qui a disparu par
rapport au profil chasse profit
production mais on peut le faire en
fonctionnant différemment et en ayant
des idées un peu on va pas dire
novatrice parce que mon système et il
est plutôt archaïque et il se rapproche
de ce qui se faisait il ya une centaine
d'années mais sait on en revient au
patrimoine et au savoir-faire qu'on
avait avant et c'est ce qui me fait
continuer
aujourd'hui on
et pour moi on est arrivé à un stade où
trou accès vers la chasse et c'est pour
moi la sologne aurait besoin d'une
ouverture enfin surtout sur le plan
environnemental
on a refermé la sologne sur des forêts
sur des friches à cause de cette culture
de la chasse qui n'était pas existantes
à l'origine on avait des milieux
beaucoup plus ouvert des landes
débrouille r&d des prairies voilà la
sologne à l'origine n'était pas qu'une
forêt et c'est ce que j'aimerais
retrouver c'est aussi mon appart mas
parti militant d'un d'essayer de rouvrir
certaines zones en friche et grâce au
comptant ce lien
[Musique]
s'ils sont élevés pour leur viande les
moutons solognot ont aussi une belle
l'aisne didier fileuse elle se fournit
en toison chez eloi un éleveur voisin
de la même presse est la tienne la
première que j'ai sorti parce que je
suis très enfants dans le lavage
pour nous la laine c'est un déchet c'est
il faut aussi même compliqué parce que
on tourne aux animaux d'un point de vue
sanitaire ce que ça ne tombe pas
naturellement donc on va pas les
martyrisant les tours dont ils en ont
besoin sauf qu'une fois que la laine on
a récolté on sait pas quoi en faire
c'est hyper important de
m valoriser ce qu'on a sur notre
territoire en fait parce que bon bah les
éleveurs ici c'est pour la viande mais
malgré tout sur le dos des moutons il ya
quand même la superbe hélène donc c'est
hyper important pour moi de battre
valoriser ce à quoi de données de sa
chance à des à une laine qui est pas
forcément valoriser en temps normal quoi
liddy a commencé à fabriquer ces pelote
il y a deux ans elle a perfectionné sa
technique pendant les confinements
que je t'aime à peine que je t'aime
que je t'aime
on s'est parlé fibre on enlève tout ce
qui est
qui mopti brindilles et tout ça mais
comme je disais ce matin avec et loire
les brebis en fait qu'ils vivent en
plein air elles ont très peu de
brindilles très peu de paille très peu
de contrairement à celles qui vivent
donc la qualité elle est vraiment plus
enfin puis c'est beaucoup plus facile à
nettoyer quoi
travailler les toisons avant de filer la
laine ces gestes ancestraux l'idylle et
reprend sans oublier que le savoir-faire
des fileuses a donné son nom à nouan le
fuzelier
s'y marient pour le libre de retour à la
ferté imbault madame le maire a sorti
les vieilles photos
je suis dans la pharmacie et parce que
ma mère était la pharmacienne du village
pendant je peux plus 30 ans refuse comme
ça ma mère est née à la ferté imbault
elle a vécu six mois la ferté après les
parties accordés sur beuvron et elle est
revenue à acheter sa pharmacie sa ferme
à six mois je suis né à romorantin
j'ai fait toute ma scolarité ici à
salbris j'ai travaillé à paris pendant
trois ans c'était intenable la région
parisienne c'est vraiment pas mon truc à
moi c'est ma sologne
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de cette nature besoin de
ces deux lots de lait des étangs
j'ai besoin voilà de de cette
température même si des fois il fait
froid l'hiver mais je devoir l'automne
les feuilles se jaunies rougir c'est au
printemps les oiseaux qui qui chante
avec une température qui est différente
parce que j'ai moi c'est l'été avec les
moustiques mes bras
pour l'édile la sologne est un condensé
de biodiversité à protéger
bon c'est d'abord aimer la nature s'est
pas engagé
sont à souligner la seule ayant des
grillages c'est pas la sologne t
respecter les animaux aussi
c'est pas les déranger quand ils mettent
bas par exemple
et puis si les briques
voilà bah l'horizon territoire aussi
parce que c'est important je trouve
d'avoir des belles maisons en sologne
un beau territoire voilà c'est la
semaine c'est beau enfin pondre et ben
maxwell
après avoir regardé les fibres de laine
et réaliser un tapis vient enfin le
temps du filage pour lydie
le wacip nautique
alors ouais c'est fait venir deux roues
et c'est comme si vous aviez fait de la
sophrologie du yoga et de la méditation
en même temps vous êtes hyper bien en
fait toutes les filles dès ce jeudi
moi je dis toujours pas en fait une
bonne philo c'est comme un cavalier et
son cheval
en fait il faut faire corps avec son
roux il faut faire qu'un avec son
la phase de filage est aussi
l'aboutissement de tout un processus et
plus encore
quand je filme mon fils je mets du jeu
mais de l'amour dedans je mets du mois
jeu mais je mets plein de choses c'est
pas juste un feed en fait et oui c'est
important donc quand je fais des marchés
de sage explique bien aux gens que c'est
moi qui trient les toisons que c'est moi
qui l'ait l'art que c'est moi qui table
que c'est moi qui filent et tout le
tralala fait il ya toujours un peu de
moi dans les fils que je fais et c'est
important je pense de donner de l'amour
aux gens en fait et du coup je me dis
que si quelqu'un sait stasi sur
madeleine parce qu'il la trouve belle ou
qui la trouve et puis il va voir ça ils
touchent et puis il va me dire oh là là
c'est que du bonheur j'ai apporté du
bonheur cinq minutes donc c'est génial
en fait
moi j'aime beaucoup donné aux autres en
fait je trouve que c'est important dans
la dans la société où on est maintenant
de donner de l'amour du sourire et un
peu de bonheur aux autres
[Musique]
reprendre les gestes d'antan se tourner
vers une agriculture plus traditionnels
ou faire revivre les centres bourgs de
villages désertés voilà comment nos
solognot envisage l'avenir sur leur
territoire chacun dans leur petit coin à
leur manière ils façonnent un autre
paysage petit à petit avec pour seul
luxe de prendre le temps
[Musique]